[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean luc lemoine les cafetières
d'aujourd'hui ils attendaient ça tous
les mercredis et c'est maintenant c'est
un bonheur aujourd'hui
et regarde bien sûr tout ce qui se passe
en coulisses qui se passe aussi pendant
l'émission il voit des trucs qu'on ne
voit pas plus fort que nous vous l'aï
dit tout à l'heure c'est le meilleur
d'entre nous ouais jean-luc on à une
question d'un téléspectateur est
exactement qui va revenir sur des sujets
plus qu'on ait évoqué pendant mon
conseil de classe à super avant le côté
artiste de matthieu delormeau avait une
caisse bonjour je m'appelle joséphine
mon rêve ce serait de rencontrer cyril
hanouna mais j'ai peur parce qu'un jour
dans la rue c'est demander un autographe
à matthieu delormeau et il m'a demandé
deux euros non est-ce que baba lui il
est vraiment sympa
la question est très bonne c'est une
question légitime joséphine mais même si
j'ai du mal à vous croire concernant
mathieu n'est pas comme ça non c'est cet
autographe ils étaient payés 5 euros
c'est lui il est aimable en toutes
circonstances même s'il en permanence
sous pression
faut juste bien le connaître pour
déceler quand il est agacé alors il faut
savoir d'où nouveau c1
les premières minutes de chaque pause
pub par exemple on sait qu'il faut pas
l'embêter nous ont laissé les invités ne
savent pas pour ça qu'à chaque fois jean
luc reichmann via lui raconter un
scénario de léo mattei
[Applaudissements]
récemment c'est rachid badouri qui est
venu le voir
j'adore le patro et bien vous allez voir
quand seuil est de vite se débarrasser
de quelqu'un il embrasse pour le dire
bonjour et 10 secondes plus tard il
embrasse pour lui dire au revoir
rachid mercedes n'a jamais su comment tu
rigoles avec plaisir quand tu me dis moi
que tu me diras on prend dix ans après
il est allé voir son spectacle arachides
idées qu'ils ont fait mais j'ai vu plein
d'extraits je vous dis il est très fort
rachid ya un talent exceptionnel je suis
d'accord c'est vraiment toi alors de
dans un autre cyrille a aussi du mal à
cacher sa mauvaise humeur
par exemple la regardez bien sa tête
vous allez voir le mec le plus veinard
au monde à ceux des gens qui n'arrivent
pas à ouvrir un bouchon de bouteille
chômage ont déçu
[Musique]
certains
j'ai eu droit à m
je
j'ai été super bel air allez un cas ben
arfa baissiers étaient vraiment veine
rsr est peu dire qu'en ce moment il a
des soucis je sais pas si vous vous
rappelez mais il s'est lancé un défi y
perdent 4 kg quinze jours tous les yeux
c'est très impressionnant 44 jours cyril
avait réussi l'exploit de passer de 82 4
kg à 82 24 kg mais oui mais ça s'appelle
la volonté ça bon depuis on la voit plus
trop la balance
à sa décharge cyril pesée se faisait à
billets donc elle a rallié en fonction
des frais reportés et d'autres choses
d'après jean-michel le lourdaud de la
semaine à lessard qui répètent 50 fois
sa blague à à la fin vous allez voir ils
ont peu plus je vais me poser la semaine
dernière là la semaine dernière je
faisais 82 kg 4 avait été le lundi
dernier ce qui est très bien j'étais pas
été pareil
voilà la mamma mia la lourdeur aller
dans les homes michel c'est le seul mec
de 55 ans qui prend encore plaisir à
dire isigny son enquête et comme un fou
dit content il est content avec lui la
france avance et c'est pour ça que cyril
est régulièrement obligés d'intégrer des
nouveaux dans l'équipe pour élever le
niveau avec daniel moreau niveau
intelligence je crois qu'il a fait une
belle prise les anges de la télé réalité
vous allez me dire souvent pensé on aura
les premières images
[Musique]
je veux effacer du feutre avec une
éponge pas gagné c'est pas gagné du tout
daniel qui a quand même a vite trouvé sa
place dans l'équipe regarder
[Applaudissements]
faire tout à l'heure à prendre un sujet
sur dance etc les stars ce soir demain
soir en direct sur tf1
on va faire un dense avec daniel
préparer moi ça les fait danser avec
daniel apparaît comme ça tu seras bien
d'accord pour le moment beaucoup de
volontaires l'impression la gueule
moi je vous aime daniel et vous êtes
formidable jeu sa main il a pesé mais
mais c'est du caca qui arrive dans
l'instant voyez il ya plein de choses et
puis on va voir l'artiste mathieu
delormeau on va revenir sur plein de
dossiers un peu bizarre
oui et on parlait dans les cas tiers de
l'humeur de cyril hanouna et j'avais de
montrer que benjamin n'était pas
toujours sympa avec la pauvre daniel
moreau c'est pour ça qu'avec cette
équipe si elle a bien du mérite à
restait d'humeur égale que me souligné
justement matthieu delormeau
[Musique]
je n'ai
live escient des chiens ont déclamé un
chien mon pauvre chéri voilà alors que
vous êtes toujours d'humeur égale ça
[Applaudissements]
commence à faire des vannes - bateau bon
mathieu n'était pas très objectif car
quand même un enfant tu as tu n'es pas
très objective est excellent car la
semaine dernière j'avais montré qui
s'est pris un gros vent et de franck
gastambide pour ceux qui l'auraient
manqué un petit rappel alors on adore ça
vous dit pauline tous les trois après
quoi regarder couler bon voilà d'or
viola d'or eh ben je dois vous avouer
une chose j'ai pas tout montrer non ah
ouais j'ai pas tout montrer en vérité
mathieu s'est pas pris un vent ah bon et
ses prix à double vendredi wu dingfu les
trois prêts quoi
en fait il ya un double vendre franck et
non non ah oui la fin de france vient de
signer ou pas le même je crois que
c'était pratiquement le même si c'est le
même un autre angle ah oui si je peux
t'on foncé d'utilisateurs sa ration pour
mathieu dans l'équipe mais il s'en fout
car lui vous le savez c'est l'ami des
stars
non on savait qu'ils avaient été à
l'école avec la machine et qui n'était
pas taillé km si la piste et le frérot
de black m
la semaine dernière on recevait laurent
baffie et mathieu était très contrarié
de savoir que laurent ne le suivait pas
sur twitter
patry
[Musique]
les yeux
je lis
demain qu'on appelle tous les ans
d'école de journée
[Applaudissements]
ouais c'est vrai ça ah pardon ouais il
est aussi poète avec baffie bon vous me
connaissez j'ai voulu vérifier quand
même et c'est vrai qu'il ya une belle
complicité entre vous allez voir au
début lors en fait un sourire poli et
très vite il se force plus du tout
[Musique]
g
[Applaudissements]
dissiper au bout du rouleau mais
maintient il s'en fout car comme il le
répète et il l'a dit c'est d'apprendre
conseil de classe lui saviez pas laâbi
c'est pas un chroniqueur c'est un
artiste l'a1 qui se produit dans des
salles immenses
contrairement à moi un sens alors 1500
personnes qui viennent pour toi eh ben
ça porte à faire si je pensais qu'ils
mentent et puis il a dit ça quand même
quels sont vos projets pour ce week-end
et les vrais projets mathieu alesi
distribuer du bonheur sur scène je le
fais souvent le week-end
effectivement je serai sur scène à
carcassonne dans le sud avec capucine
d'ailleurs qui me suivra qui sera mon
assistante non
[Applaudissements]
elle dérange st voilà ça dérangeait
j'arrive le dérange et souvent même dans
l'émission alors je pense je pensais
qu'il était fou mais en fait il était
vraiment spectacle amer à carcassonne
[Musique]
et complet
et il a
bref on pensait
vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les nuisibles
voilà c'est vrai je retiens tout cela
dit je vais faire l'olympia mais je me
sens tout petit à côté de preuves on va
boire carcassonne face à un vrai artiste
alors là mais je baise moi aussi j'adore
chez les embrasse très fort voilà merci
la prochaine fois je serai avec vous par
contre ne payez pas de verre et si
mathieu dit qu'on entend parler de lui
dans le cinéma basse et c'est surtout
parce que c'est un [ __ ] de comédiens
ont leur voix juste deux secondes jouer
la surprise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça a l'air sympa ces petites soirées
gégousse irina oui oui vraiment pour
vendre tous les week-ends l'émission va
bien falloir vous aime je suis votre
représentant le week-end mais
demanderait 10 % pour ça bien sûr qu'il
oeuvrait pour l'argent on prête pour
l'argent c'est vrai nom c'est à dire que
là tu peux dire à toutes les boîtes de
nuit que tu ferais gratuitement aux
chaînes regarde l'heure qu'il est déjà
enfin il ya une chose qui m'étonne c'est
je passe pas beaucoup de temps en boîte
mais mets dans mes souvenirs les gens
sont pas tous torse nu à chaque fois on
ne vole les fringues comment ça se passe
en tout cas c'était chaud avec +1
ils se sont frottés énormément et vous
allez voir comme c'est un bon comédien
quand il veut susurré quelque chose
alors et d'une fille
ben il le dit dans un micro en
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
nous ça c'est la folie de huy jouvet
made in salah et la solide base sur l
appui dont c'était le conseil de classe
semaine dernière est d'ailleurs elle
était super inquiète et boucau hésité
entre admiration et consternation et la
consternation l'a largement emporté
je vous mets un essai généreux ils ne
savent pas quelles raisons c'est dur
c'est dur car je vais vous dire une
petite révélation comme ça pour avoir
une bonne note
elle avait bossé tout le week-end
regardez là
c'est ce que j'aurais dû lire
[Applaudissements]
reste qu'en ppp sera une émission média
country cabu sénat sera au top que pour
l'ambiance de l'équipe je sais pas si
c'était une riche idée les conseils de
classe ça rend tout le monde nerveux
ah oui même ceux qu'on croit hermétique
à la critique regarder
[Musique]
franchement votre vision est parfois
altéré mais je vous aime d'un amour
extraordinaire et donc c'est avec
énormément de tendresse
je vous mets de l'incroyable 3,2 à une
hôtesse de matthieu delormeau ya
beaucoup de gens qui veulent participer
à qui veulent donner des rations seul
coup gilles gottie dans l'émission série
nous a également demandé de présenter
nos excuses sur ce qu'on voulait et
thierry avait décidé de s'excuser d'être
trop drôle
en m'attaquant en plus ce qui est moche
donc j'ai voulu être objectif et et voir
les effets des blagues de thierry sur
les chroniqueurs en comparaison avec un
vrais humoristes je vous laisse juger
chers compatriotes les plus plates pour
les vannes que je fais parfois pour le
niveau qu'elles ont j'ai bien conscience
de tirer un peu la couverture à moi et
un de faire un peu d'ombré jean luc
lemoine
c'est une femme vient d'accoucher alors
on lui met le bébé sur le ventre les
murs elle regarde elle fond en larmes
elle regarda dit quand je pense qu'il ya
neuf mois je faillite avaler la fait que
des tests bleus le plus les enfants
couach a déjà fait que détestent le plus
les enfants
l'afld était de voir la tête des épaules
j'adore je viens les massues ans ça va
pas vous plaire ah non je vous connais
et ça c'est vous détestez sa images
choquantes de la semaine
non on sait que mathieu fait attention à
son alimentation qui mange sain et qui
respecte son public
ouais et bien visiblement ils n'arrivent
pas à faire les deux en même temps non
[Applaudissements]
alors ça ça ne me plaît pas du tout non
plus je ne reconnais pas banal avait pas
un visage a franchement ça attention c
est bien son conseil d'occasion qui aura
une sanction aux red sox ou te plaît et
bars de parfois les gens aiment bien
juste des excuses je suis et vous auprès
de votre public bas et surtout auprès de
la de la jeune fille ou du jeune garçon
qui à mon avis des digues a dû le garder
quand même mais en tous les cas je
présente mes excuses à celui qui a reçu
ce grain aller mais en tout cas ça fait
une magnifique transition bien la
première fois qu'il plante la graine on
va voir tout ce qu'on n'aurait pas voulu
voir justement et ans par semaine et on
commence par cyril qui rayonne bensetti
avait offert un magnifique lego géant à
son effigie il aurait pas dû non délai
une enquête exclusive qui était hostile
sac à dos
[Applaudissements]
qu'acheter cette petite bête sat après
oui voilà je vous le dis les aides sont
la spécialité de quoi les helvètes les
étés les élèves de cette once est bien
chargé mais bon on peut trouver des
trous du cul j'avais étudié l'art au
chaud
sous je les ai mis la note de 8 passes
il vous rend hommage et il vous aime
arthur je pense qu'il vous aime
sincèrement donc réconcilier le jour
[Applaudissements]
trouvez limites de ses noces rebelles
rappelons aux réverbères des jeunes trop
la chronique à titi c'est la chronique à
titi les chiffres des ch'tis c'est une
nouveauté
en tout cas ils les portent bien je
trouve qu'ils ont bien oui moi la saison
3 est revenue me débaucher pas me
chercher dans une salle de sport pour
être tentateur dans la saison 3 de glee
la tentation tentateur dans les
internationaux qui répondait lui les
gens c'est comme les bons
[Musique]
le mal est fait
[Applaudissements]